I don't even care even after seeing the
crickety a shaky-cam rockets I'd still
go into space first man
so first man's directed by Damien
Chazelle he directed whiplash he direct
his la-la-land he stars Ryan Gosling as
Neil Armstrong Neil Armstrong is first
man first man to walk on the moon hence
the title this isn't necessarily the
story of the Apollo 11 mission though we
do see it it's the story of all the
drama and the bumps in the road leading
to landing on the moon see when
something happens that is a worldwide
televised event that's described as one
giant leap for mankind it's easy to
concentrate on the end product and
overlook the bumps bruises blood sweat
and tears that were shed to get there so
now we get a peek behind the curtain
into that story Ryan Gosling of course
is great in this movie he's great period
he he does still do the Ryan Gosling
thing that is Ryan Gosling can have the
most screen time with the fewest lines
in a movie what can I say dude comes
across as very stoic a lot of the time
but that might be in character for Neil
Armstrong I don't know what Neil
Armstrong was like but in this movie
comes across as very binary looks like
in this movie he was created by design
to be very calculating and very
mathematical which means although he
does show emotional tension in the movie
when the stress of the entire ordeal is
coming down on the family clarify plays
his wife she doesn't really good job to
a lot of it falls on her to show how
stressful this situation is Neil
Armstrong looks like he's on emotional
lockdown for a lot of the movie so she's
the one showing a lot of the emotional
tears and I like the fact that it showed
that this this weight on their shoulders
isn't just on the astronauts on the
family of the astronauts to the big
weight to carry but my favorite element
of the movie is just the technical
aspect of it at a point I started seeing
like film grain and film speckle in the
movie I was like is this 35 millimeter
sometimes it looks like 16 millimeter I
don't know if they use 16 millimeter or
35 millimeter possibly to make it look
like 16 millimeter 20 does it looks a
little grainy er than usual I'm not
saying that it's like the movie didn't
look Chris I'm saying I like the fact
that it looked a little grainy it looked
like something from the time if you feel
the movie that supposed to take place in
the 60s in super crisp digital it'll
still feel like the sixties sure but if
you make the quality of the film look
like it's from the 60s rather than 2018
it's just one more element of immersion
you have you're not only telling a story
of a time but it also looks like it's a
movie from the time there was a nice
detail I appreciate it but for the lunar
sequence that was filmed with IMAX if
you see this movie in an IMAX theatre
you will see
contrast of the grainy 35-millimeter
that we got leading up to the IMAX
clarity it's actually pretty
awe-inspiring there was not a sound in
the theater when it happened it was
crazy at some degree I kind of know what
my grandmother felt like when she first
saw The Wizard of Oz and Dorothy walks
out of her black and white house and
it's just everything's in color I
understand it's not going to be exactly
that but still same kind of feeling also
I have no idea what is CGI and what's
practical there are so many shots in
this movie that's like the top gun angle
no camera on the wing aiming back at the
tab and you see the clouds and the earth
spinning behind it but those clouds get
really small because they go really high
seeing that transition of when it's
daytime and the blue of sky turns to
black effective I don't know if it's
real I don't know if I don't know also
scenes in pretty much any cockpit there
were a lot of test runs that happened
before we were actually like alright
let's go to the moon and in any cockpit
scene which this movie pretty much
starts out with one of them it is
unsettling it feels like what it pretty
much actually is someone's strapped to a
garbage can there just being launched
the sound is comparable to when the
velociraptors were being fed in the
original Jurassic Park mixed with
explosions like that it's a really
unsettling sound you're like I'm
probably gonna die a lot of shaky-cam to
but this isn't an action sequence it's
not like you're supposed to have
everything framed up alright let me see
the action why is it shaky cam it's
supposed to be shaky is supposed to be
unsettling you're supposed to be in the
cockpit and that's how it is you're not
flying on Virgin America first class
here it's gonna get bumpy the movie
successfully walks the tricky line of
asking I mean wasn't worth it when
people died people died so we could go
to the moon to essentially tell Russia
ha we did it first so you have to just
stop and be like is it worth these
people no longer being around no longer
existing they are no longer alive
however while asking that question
it doesn't undercut the scope of the
gravity of the situation of we went to
the moon that's inspired generations of
people to come that's the stuff that
dreams are made of it expands
imagination it makes people go hey
what's an X I guess Mar is over half a
century later one thing the movie
doesn't portray or do so well is show
the passage of time this whole story
takes place in the span of about eight
years and at the beginning of the movie
his wife goes from not pregnant too
pregnant to now he has a kid and in that
time he's on what seems like day two of
his space training but it can't be day
two we're on like month nine when you
really sit down and look at it this
whole movie takes place in the span of
eight years it does not feel like eight
years
at all I do feel like this movies not
the drama it wanted to be like it's not
as impactful as it aimed for and I don't
know if that's because Neil Armstrong's
one of the most stoic people in US
history or if it's because Ryan Gosling
portrayed Neil Armstrong is one of the
most stoic people in cinematic history
I don't know Neil Armstrong and ever met
him I haven't talked to his family quite
possible that Neil Armstrong just
doesn't lend himself to drama because
he's a very stoic mathematical person
who doesn't show emotion even when you
see the emotion at home it doesn't it
doesn't hit you in the heart just more
or less makes you nod like yeah I'm glad
they addressed that so it's a very
interesting movie it's a fascinating
look behind the curtain very intense
when you're in the cockpit I just feel
like this movie should have hit me in
the feels a little more maybe I'm
heartless
I humor that because in the end first
man was really enjoyable it was a
dramatic peek behind the curtain of the
legend the legend of the event the
legend of the man you see the humanity
and I love that I love the fact that
people who are deemed heroes they're
still human beings they're flawed human
beings like the rest of the onlooker
flawed human beings and I like it when a
movie explores that the movie does have
a two hour 20 minute runtime so be
prepared for a two hour 20 minute drama
and I will say first man's really
enjoyable really good time no alcohol
required right so first man have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know do you think Elon Musk is
actually going to Mars or do you think
he's going to the asteroids to bring an
asteroid back so we can be the world's
first illionaire come on that's really
what he's doing and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]